[Music]
Lucas and Aria had this moment where
Lucas was getting confronted intrical
maybe he didn't do it there's nothing
coincidental and pretty the wires though
you know are you glad that we noticed
that glad you didn't notice that yeah
that was supposed to be a really subtle
thing it was in that was written in the
script that was not an improvised thing
so it was a very specific moment if you
learn a little bit more about that in
future episode so is it possible then
that Lucas is still working with or for
or is ad it's possible anything's
possible yeah I hope that after seeing
like that last scene that people you
know cut Lucas some slack so maybe if he
is involved with the whole thing yeah
they realize that there is a motive
behind it I'll say this if he is
involved I think it's for that kind of
reason where he is trying to protect
Hanna oh so you think to protect Hanna
protect Hanna yeah you know for good
reason anything if he is involved it's
for a good reason
should viewers go back to season 3
season 2 and try to figure out the clues
does it go that far back absolutely yeah
yeah absolutely I won't tell you what
specific clues that there are but there
are hints that have been dropped for a
long time it's exciting and it's it's
these last four episodes in particular I
think starting with last night are
really ramping up to that final moment
moment what was your reaction you
discovered who ad was oh um very
surprised I was thrown off yes I wasn't
expecting it did you have more questions
when you found out who it was like did
you go back and try to piece it together
yeah yeah when I found out who it was
obviously I hadn't read the script yet
because it was a couple weeks in advance
on and it didn't make total sense to me
at first um and then when I saw this rip
and I read it and we all sat down and
the people that are involved with those
scenes do a really really phenomenal job
um
and it all the questions are answered
and it made sense once I actually saw
what was on page will fans get to see on
the show in the script I guess play out
all the times yes
um there are there are a lot of
flashbacks in the finale so you you will
you will see those things and several
the things are like you said are not
only just spoken they've actually see it
[Music]
you